One of the things that happens in the old testament is Israel struggles up to
state and empire status six times its struggles out of the chaos,
up to empire status,
and then it gets corrupt.
It loses the way it isn't.
Balancing things between chaos and order properly that the kings get arrogant.
It's so to the people and they forget their relationship with God.
That's another way of thinking about it.
And then a profit comes up and says,
you aren't paying enough attention to the widows and the orphans.
You better look out because that displeases God and the Israelites who are stiff
necked and arrogant think what's God going to do to us,
which is not a very wise way of thinking.
And so they don't take the steps necessary to rectify their deviation from the
proper path.
And they get absolutely flattened and the consequences of that last for
generations,
like seven generations.
And then they struggle their way up to something approximating empire status
again.
And exactly the same thing happens.
They forget and they collapse.
And there's six stories like that in the Old Testament.
It's all deep documented by a man named Northrop Frye,
who is a Canadian literary critic who wrote a couple of books on the Bible,
one called the great code and the other called words with power,
which I would highly recommend.
It's an analysis of the Bible as literature.
Brilliant.
For those of you who might be interested in union thinking,
Fry's thinking is a nice adjunct.
So all right,
so,
so that's the nature of the world order chaos and order.
And your goal is to keep those,
the relationship between those two things optimized.
And you do that by doing what's meaningful,
not what's expedient.
That's rule six and you ensure that you have the world construed property by
following rule number eight,
which is tell the truth,
or at least don't lie.
You don't want to pathologize the instinct that orients you in the world and you
will pathologize it by engaging in habitual deceit.
And the reason you do that is when you practice something,
you build structures that specialize in that and then they run automatically.
So if you're living a lie,
which is a very common thing for people to do,
then you're building neurological mechanisms that view the world through that
lie.
And once they're built,
they're you and good luck unbuilding them.
It's very,
very difficult.
That's in part what happens to people who are addicted by the way they build
mechanisms of search,
neurological structures that are focused on the drug and those systems are alive
and all they want is the drug and they're,
they're not,
it's not psychological.
Exactly.
It's psychophysiological don't build structures of cognition predicated on
deception because you will pay for it.
And so if you're going to guide your life with the orientation of the instinct
of meaning,
then you have to be very careful with what you say and write and think.
Because every time you say or write or think something,
you build a little neurological structure that's specialized for that and it
participates in this parsing of the world.
So all right,
chaos and order.
Then you can say the order orders a hierarchy.
Okay,
so here's the next question.
Next two questions is order a hierarchy.
And then a subsidiary question would be,
if order is a hierarchy,
what's,
well,
either what is at the top of the hierarchy or what should be at the top of the
hierarchy instead of hierarchies,
a structure value.
So that's the question is what should be of all come at value.
Okay,
so now we're going to take that apart a little bit.
The first thing I would say is order is not a hierarchy.
Order is a set of hierarchies.
That's a different thing.
So,
uh.